my name is Michael swirling I'm the
proud owner of ksco News Talk am180 and
fm104.1 in Santa Cruz California a place
where there are more characters per
square inch than anywhere on the planet
it was a lifelong dream for me to own
this station from the time I was a high
school kid and in
1991 25 years ago I was able to realize
that lifelong dream but became careful
what you wish for because even though I
was so passionate about running a radio
station that serves the community we did
a very good job of serving the community
but guess what it didn't pay financially
it was almost impossible to sell enough
advertising to pay what it costs to run
a radio operation like this and that's
why you won't find a talk radio station
anywhere in the country or probably in
the world that's anything like ksco I'm
going to share with you the secret of
our success and Longevity for the last
25 years we have been able to
do almost The Impossible and that is
because I joined a company called
youngevity founded by Dr Joel wallik an
absolutely amazing person I'm very proud
to present the following video
presentation that has just blown me away
Dr wallik has a message that everybody
needs to see and I want to share it with
you starting right now this is about
your Health and
Longevity hello I'm Dr Joel wallik and
we're here to talk about Health and
Longevity today and the thing that makes
my view different is that I have a
degree in agriculture I'm a veterinarian
I wrote the first paper in a mass Dio
from pollution in America
1961 I am a comparative pathologist
ologist and I've done 20,000 autopsies
177,000 some change over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 humans this was for
the center for the biology of natural
systems a composite of Washington
University St Louis the St Louis Zoo and
the Shaw's Botanical Gardens and I also
have a degree in post-doctoral
Fellowship in comparative pathology
which is the equivalent of a PhD in
compared pathology and I'm a primary
care physician since 1982 I've been
licensed as a prim care physician a
naturopathic physician from Argan
licensed in argon and I'm also licensed
in California again as a primary care
physician and of course this gives me a
different view on things what you're
going to see here in this presentation
is why we're in trouble why our children
are die before we do they they are going
to be the first generation Americans who
do not live as long as their parents why
our food is depleted of of nutrients has
nothing to do with pollution and we have
a real problem here and what you're
going to find find is we're going to
give you Solutions and we can all win
this game together um but everybody's
going to have to be obsessive about
making these things happen so here we go
and of course uh you're seeing here some
of the various Awards I've won so it
gives me a little
credibility and uh I graduated
agricultural school at the University of
Missouri I graduated veter school at the
University of Missouri and before
graduating veter School actually started
taking courses in pathology and this is
me getting an award at the United
Nations for natural medicine Lifetime
Achievement Award for natural medicine
and philanthropy and the um Ambassador
on the right side of your picture is uh
this wonderful lady she's the Ambassador
from Nepal and the gentleman on your
left is the ambassador from Dubai the
UAE the United Arab Emirates and this is
off the stage after receiving the word
this is kind of the red carpet thing and
this is me in 19 well this is me in 20
2011 getting the CLA Schwarz award for
Trac metal research in the prevention
reversal of birth defs and most of you
have heard or read the audio cast that
tape the CD or the book Dead Doctors
Don't Lie uh the CD is in 12 different
languages all over the world and it's
sold over 300 million copies we're very
very proud of that obviously somebody's
interested in the message now this is a
word cloud and it's just going to be a
brief introduction to some of the
concepts we're talking about we get into
the details so you know where we're
going I want you look in the upper right
hand corner and you'll notice it says
obesity the prevailing theory for 100
years on Obesity has been obesity is
caused by eating too much and lack of
exercise well we followed that theory
for a hundred years and what did we get
we're the number one obese nation of the
world it's a failed Theory basically
being overweight and obese is really due
to a deficiency of a certain group of
nutrients and if any one of them are
missing you're going to start gaining
some weight there are several of those
nutrients in that group if you're
missing them you're going to weigh 400
600 800 pounds and so obesity can be
gotten rid of very quickly but you have
to supplement with these nutrients and
then the Cravings the munchies the binge
eating goes away very simply you can
lose a half a pound or two pounds a day
we'll talk more about that in detail in
a moment the red rectangle uh just below
obesity has the word Alzheimer's in it
Alzheimer disease is certainly not
caused by eating aluminum or being in
contact with aluminum deodorant we're
looking at a disease that say physici
caused disease alimer disease is a
physician caused disease not caused by
aluminum absolutely not genetic it's a
simple nutritional deficiency disease
driven by doctors telling people to do
things telling their patients to give up
cholesterol and saturated fat it's a
cholesterol deficiency we'll talk more
about this in a moment then there's
cardiovas disease this is probably one
of the biggest hoaxes because it's
proactive it's in other words it was
consciously done um to sell another
product and this is where proctoring
able to make long story short um
ultimately bought the patents for a
substance that was used as a submarine
diesel engine lubricant a smokeless
lubricant originally and after the war
they didn't need it as a submarine
diesel engine lubricant anymore and so
Proctor and Gamble wound up with it and
they were going to sell it as soap and
they couldn't sell it as soap because
people were making their own soap and
they decided to use it as a shortening
for cooking but they had to demonize
what Grandma had been using for
centuries and that is lard butter cream
and eggs for cooking and what they did
again to make a long story short through
anel Keys who is on the board of Proctor
and Gamble and also on the board of the
American Heart Association uh he
brokered a deal in which the Proctor and
Gamble gave a $1.7 million Grant to the
American Heart Association in in
exchange for an endorsement of this
diesel lubricant as a replacement for
lard buttercream and demonization of
cholesterol ands saturated fat also they
came up with the idea of the
Mediterranean dot to sort of make it
more sexy to give those things up
Mediterranean Dot and it's turned out
that these are all false things we'll
talk about that more in a minute in
detail but basically congestive heart
failure one of the more common causes of
heart disease in adults all over the
industrialized world is due to a
deficiency of a single vitamin we've
known that for 300 years it was proposed
by Japanese Naval surgeon 300 years ago
cardiopathy heart disease I'm very
familiar with that it's a deficiency of
a single mineral and you see this
resulting in sudden deaths in athletes
or sudden deaths in people who do hard
physical work I've actually done 1,700
autopsy on kids under the age of 10 that
have died of this one in kesan Province
China deficiency of a single mineral has
nothing to do with cholesterol or
saturated fat then there's coronary
artery disease that has nothing to do
with saturated fat or cholesterol
coronary artery disease and I said this
in 1971 after doing 20,000 autopsies on
the big NIH project with a center for
the center of Disease Control and also
um for the center of the biological
systems and it's one of those things
where this was a a joint project between
Washington University and in St Louis
the St Louis Zoo in the Botanical Garden
Sha's Botanical Gardens and Marlon
Perkins okay and Barry commoner those
two guys put this together and brought
me back from Africa I was doing research
and conservation work with the white
Rono and the African elephant came back
for two years after that project and uh
began to do these autopsies 177,000 some
change of over um let's see 454 species
of animals and 3,000 humans and the 1200
page book that came out that is in the
Smithsonian Institute and the bottom
line of this finding of this 10-year
project was that every animal and every
human being who dies of what we' call
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency disease not pollution and
certainly not genetics so it was kind of
um a surprised everybody but that's what
the study showed and everybody agreed
with the research and so coronary artery
disease again is not caused by
cholesterol or Satur fat it's actually
caused by inflammation which was said in
that book which is in the smithonian
Institute and um it's caused by
inflammation caused by eating
inflammatory foods fried foods processed
Meats oils yes oils and gluten we'd
brought around oats and then there's
coronary thrombosis one of my nine um
lawsuits against the FDA and federal
court and we want the ability to say
that coronary thrombosis is not caused
by cholesterol ins saturated fat but is
caused by actually a deficiency of
Omega-3 essential fatty acids and are a
ratio problem between Omega-3s sixes and
nines then you jump over to arthritis in
the lower left hand corner and arthritis
in fact is simply a multi mineral and
multivitamin deficiency disease ratard
has a secondary infection with
micoplasma bug that's easily killed in a
couple of weeks with an antibotic called
Minocycline member of the tetracycline
family then you go straight up from
arthritis in this word cloud to diabetes
and diabetes has nothing to do with
genetics it's not a genetically
transmitted disease type two diabetes
which makes up 98% of the diabetic
population is in fact due to
a simple deficiency of a single mineral
we've known that for almost 80 years now
and of course this allows us to prevent
and support the body's ability to heal
itself when you have type two diabetes
it's one of those Little Miracles
because uh an example would be if uh you
have iron deficiency anemia instead of
wanting to just give you an iron
supplement to solve the problem medical
doctors want to do a bone marrow
transplant that's why we have such
complicated procedures and treatments
for diabetes when it's really a very
simple Minal deficiency disease and of
course in the beginning of time when
human beings began to record things and
tell stories into their famili so they
get messages passed down they believed
that diseases were caused by evil
spirits or things up in the universe
that they had no control over and they
knew there was infectious disease they
didn't know the word infection but they
knew they were transmitted and they were
very dangerous diseases they put
writings on Cave walls these cave walls
in the cave art they had pictures of
shamans treating people with infections
and wounds and then of course astrology
is where they believe this and we're
talking about Physicians now as well as
the patients believed that people would
get sick because they angered Gods up in
planets and if they would sacrifice
either animals or even their neighbors
to these gods they would be appeased and
would look kindly upon them and let them
survive through epidemics and plagues or
maybe prevent them from getting disease
or um allow them to have healthy
children and in more recent times maybe
in the last 500 years um medical doctors
got rid of their competition by going to
churches and telling them that the
grandma Ruthie was healing people with
her herbs it was really God's job to
heal people and not this witch and the
church would send out Inquisition
committees to torture these poor
grandmothers into confessing that they
were a witch and then they would burn
them at the stake and so the churches
were involved in helping eliminate the
competition for doctors doctors
originally believed um in the last
thousand years that diseases were caused
by an imbalance of different fluids in
the body the humors they called them IM
balance of the humors and there was
blood and Flem and urine and yellow bow
and black bow and the way that they
would balance them back was to use blood
leting they put leeches on you suck
blood out or they would just cut veins
on the surface and allow a certain
amount of blood to drain out and of
course Physicians killed our first
President George Washington by Blood
letting him when he had a respiratory
infection the first guy to really look
at nutritional deficiencies in Western
world was a guy by the name of schusler
and he was a hospital in in German
hospitals and when in patients would die
after months or longer in hospitals he'
cremate the bodies and analyze the
minerals in their ashes and then he
would actually compare and relate the
different mineral levels in these bodies
in the ashes with their symptoms and
when people come in with those same
symptoms he would give them those
minerals and he' able to cure many many
people and these became known these
minerals became known as shler cell Sals
we're talking about magnesium and
phosphorus sodium um sulf fur silica
calcium phosphorus I said Iron and
potass all of these things were given
and people would get cured so schusler
is one of the first ones to point to
mineral deficiencies as possible causes
of certain
diseases the FDA moved from the seven
food group pyramid to the plate now
their Mantra has been to the general
public that just eat well you get
everything you need eat plenty of uh
dark fruits and vegetables to get
antioxidants and also eat four food RS
you're going to get everything you need
don't supplement you could overdose and
this has been a terrible terrible
terrible uh event in Humanity's
development because as you would see in
a moment you cannot get everything you
need just by eating foods of different
colors and eating well pharmaceutical
has got started with u patent medicines
of course we're talking about Professor
Smith's or Dr Frank's liver tonic which
was usually um whiskey that they had
home brewed and one of the first ones uh
here in America was a a fellow a German
fellow with the name of a bear actually
saw people relieving their pain and
their suffering by chewing on white
willow bark and he made an alcohol
extract of it a tincture if you will and
dried out the and got a powder made a
pill out of it and called it bare Asma
and was able to relieve pain that was
one of the first over-the-counter truly
what we wouldd call an over-the-counter
drug today Coca-Cola was also one of the
first Pharmaceuticals it was actually
cocaine to be begin with it was a
cocaine in liquid form Coca Cola and
when it became necessary to pull the
cocaine out of it because it became a
prescription item what we have here is
they they would put caffeine from coffee
into the cocacola they carbonated it and
made it something that everybody could
drink in the uh little little drugstores
before there was um proac for depression
medical doctors would write
prescriptions for cigarettes for
depression and when it became known that
smoking tobacco or chewing tobacco
increased the risk of um lung cancer and
mouth cancer oral cancer and so forth um
Everybody sued the tobacco companies and
the medical doctors got a walk um they
were writing prescriptions for 30 40
years for tobacco they were the ones who
were intimately involved in causing lung
cancer but nobody ever sued a doctor for
that because everybody went to the Deep
Pockets of the pharmaceutical companies
uh which were at that time the tobacco
companies hospitals over charge people
by as much as a
th% in modern times 85% of all personal
bankruptcies are due to medical bills
85% of all personal bankruptcies are due
to medical bills it's a very very scary
Prospect when you think about it and
most of the debt in America and other
industrialized nations comes from
medical bills people think they're
getting free medical care but they're
paying $6 a gallon gasoline uh in taxes
to pay for the free medical care so it's
not really free but uh it buys a lot of
votes to say you're going to give free
medical care to people if you vote for
me right and the reason why this goes on
is most people don't go through their
statements that come in from the
insurance companies and when the
statements come they just look it's an
insurance statement they throw it in the
drawer without opening it and so nobody
notice that um hospitals are charging
insurance companies $500 for a single
rubber glove and so on and they continue
to get away with it the number of
Americans using five or more drugs
nearly doubles okay 59% of American
adults are on prescription drugs 59%
this is very very scary this is legal
drug dealing is what it amounts to and
of course most prescription drugs with
the exception of antibiotics do not cure
anything with the exception of
antibiotics which do cure infections uh
things like bacterial menitis bacterial
pneumonia abscesses bacterial intestinal
infections and so forth um but other
than antibiotics there's not a single
drug that cures anything they all treat
symptoms they all relieve symptoms some
do a very good job some have terrible
side effects in including death death
rates Rising for Middle AG white
Americans okay this just came out you
see November
2015 the death rates were Rising for
middle-aged white Americans while
declining for other wealthy countries
and among other races and ethnic groups
the rise appears to be driven by Suicide
drugs and alcohol abuse but but when you
look at these people who are committing
suicide and who are abusing alcohol and
drugs these are ones who have 6 8 10 12
15 terrible diseases degenerative
diseases chronic diseases making their
lives miserable and none of the drugs
are taking or helping them they're
driven to look for something that's
going to give them relief here's one guy
who kind of overdid it and you start
billing for one patient $5 million a
month for drug therapy for cancer they
didn't have well he got his hand caught
in the cookie jar put in jail for 175
years and in fact many many many more
doctors should be put on trial for the
same problems when doctors don't know
what you have when they don't know what
you have as far as a disease they say
you have an autoimmune disease your
body's attacking itself that way it
takes takes the responsibility away from
them gosh instead of saying I I really
don't know I have to do a little bit of
research to find out in the meantime I'm
going to give you this drug to give you
some relief they never do that they say
oh you have an autoimmune disease your
body's attacking itself not much I can
do for you or you have a genetic disease
you're you just have bad genes there's
not much I can do for you okay it's not
my fault well let's have a look CAT
scans are linked to cancer because they
have as much as 500 chest Rays worth of
radiation for one CAT scan even the
government says use them limit you know
on a limited basis in fact most of the
time you shouldn't even use a canat scan
Harvard Medical School said that 20
years ago Don't Use CAT scans okay
because of the radiation dangers they're
linked to breast cancer and other forms
of death the mamogram is not a
prevention repeat that mammograms are
not prevention they also have as much as
500 chest x-rays worth of radiation and
one mammogram why would you do that well
I've been going to the same obn for 25
years I really respect him and he said I
really should get a mamogram so I did
women should get three and four
different um opinions before they make
choices like this and there's other
options a higher resolution ultrasound
would give you the same information
without the radiation of course in
ultrasound the doctor might only make 50
bucks where in a a mamogram he might
make 1200 now this story in the Japanese
newspapers kind of gives you the the
idea of what's Happening Here with
Medical Care in all industrialized
nations if you notice um medical care
expenses in Japan have increased from
two TR yen in 1970 as 2 trillion Tren a
year in 1970 to 37 trillion yen a year
in 2009 and in 2014 it was actually 40
trillion yen for one year 2014 well you
want to note that Japanese tax revenues
in 2013 total from all tax revenues the
country was 42.3 trillion so the doctors
were paid 40 trillion of that only 2.3
trillion was left over to do the
business of the government now you see
why governments are going bankrupt all
governments the industrialized world are
going bankrupt because of the cost of
inefficient dangerous and ineffective
Medical Care genetics is another failed
theory of the 20th and 21st century
there's not a single disease that's
transmitted genetically there's not a
single disease that is um transmitted
genetically as birth effects all birth
effects are caused by nutritional
deficiency of the embryo the concept of
adults passing on information whether
you're an oak tree or a fish or a human
being or hummingbird or crocodile goes
back to the days of Charles Darwin
people had noticed these things but
Charles Darwin was the first one to
write it down and uh his cousin Francis
gton U really enjoyed what darwi was
saying in his book On the Origin of
Species and began a little sort of
pseudo science called Eugenics and this
started the entire world in a race for
Gathering up territory because everybody
wanted to be the master race remember
this sort of stuff went on in the 1800s
but Hitler picked it up in the 1930s
before the second world war and took
Eugenics to a horrible horrible level uh
in which oh I don't know the Nazis
killed over 40 million people who they
thought weren't worthy of living kind of
like um selection in farm animals if you
have one that doesn't meet your criteria
for production or or standards of looks
you eat them okay and so he was killing
people who didn't meet his standards of
the perfect generation Gregor mendle
priest was the first one to talk about
things like um recessive and dominance
he understood that in hybrids he was he
was a priest and and he found out all
this information by studying PE Plants
and how they work when you began to
hybridize different types of pee plants
very very smart guy 1800s Louis pasture
invented the germ Theory and he was a
wine chemist and he invented
pasteurization he would heat wine
prevent it from going to vinegar and he
knew that fermentation then was a
biological process
and uh he also knew once he looked
through the first microscope which was
invented by a Dutch eyeglasses maker Von
Luen Hoke he could see yeast actually
growing in fermenting wine and beer and
so he knew his biological process he
heated it and stopped the process so it
didn't go to vinegar doctors still at
the time believed that the um
fermentation process was a chemical
process and as a result when you heated
it it actually went faster sometimes
explosively 1961 I was able to find as a
graduate student I had graduated a
school I'm halfway through vener school
and taking graduate courses in pathology
found the first Mass die off in America
from pollution did the research found
out how it happened exactly tracked all
the chemistries got a published this my
first publication I gave a copy to
Marlon Perkins and this is how he was
interested in me doing the autopsies in
his project for the center for the
biology of natural systems again the
founding members were the University or
Washington University of St Louis St
Louis olical Garden St Louis Zoo and
Shaw's botanical gardens Barry commoner
okay really a very very smart fellow
when it came to biology and Marlon
Perkins who's one of my mentors and he
remembered that paper I had given him on
the first MTI from pollution and so I
was in Africa working in the white
Ronald conservation project in the
African elevation and he sent me a
letter invied me back to um work on this
project with the center for the biology
of natural system be the pathologist on
the project because I had given him this
paper on pollution and they believe that
pollution was a a basic root cause of um
of diseases of natural causes and they
wanted me to do autopsies in zoo animals
that lived in big zoos in the big cities
of the United States and they wanted to
use the zoo animals in these big zoos
United States as the canary in the mine
like the old Welsh coal miners would
take canaries down in the mine if gases
would leak into the mine the canaries
were more sensitive than men and they
would drop off the perge and die long
before the men were in danger and they
could get out safely and they felt that
with big zoos having 400 500 600 species
of animals that um they could get
information before we actually got hurt
and they actually froze bodies and sent
them to me from zoos all over North
America Canada United States and Mexico
for this project this is the book that
came out of it this book disease of
exotic animals 1,200 Pages covers 20,000
autopsies 10 million chemistries and is
in the Smithsonian Institute is a
National Treasure I'm very very proud of
that work all birth defects are caused
by nutritional deficiencies during the
development of the embryo the embryo's
gone down essentially an assembly line
if anything's missing this required for
the production of cells or tissues or
organs there's something missing at that
appropriate time during the first
trimester of pregnancy guess what you're
going to get a defect because
something's going to be missing by the
time 1910 1920 came along we knew the
chemical analyses we knew the
biochemistry of genes and DNA and RNA
but nobody really knew the physical
structure and so it was kind of delaying
genetic engineering because nobody knew
the physical structure well in 1953
these two young fellas here um James
Watson from the United States and fr
Francis Crick from England proposed a
double helix and it took nine years it
went all the way until 1962 before the
general science Community agreed with
him and they got the Nobel Prize for it
that time James Watson was named the
director of The Cold Springs genetic
research laboratory for the federal
government in New York in Manhattan
Island and between 2003 and 2011 the
human genome was mapped out we knew
every Gene that's found in the human
body and 850 botch companies were formed
and spent trillions and trillions and
trillions of dollars looking for
screening tests would alert us early on
that a child say 2 years old when they
when they're 48 is going to get Park and
disase or when they're 52 are going to
get breast cancer prostate cancer or
colon cancer and they could genetically
engineer the proper healthy genes
replace the bad genes and thus eliminate
the appearance of the disease later on
that was the whole idea of genetic
engineering when born errors of
metabolism were thought to be genetic
because people were born with these
diseases and doctors erroneously falsely
believed uh that they were due to genes
or genetics one of the more common ones
is calel anemia primarily found in the
black community as Cel anemia and I was
Finding Cel anemia in Deer and in
antelopes and in
hummingbirds and how could a human
genetic disease wind up in in these
animals and so that was my question and
it turns out that this is not a
genetically transmitted disease it's
called an inborn air metabolism during
early pregnancy the third to the seventh
week of pregnancy mother's missing a
mineral and what happens is the system
that manufactures good hemoglobin is um
not correct because things were missing
when it was farming and so you get a
dysfunctional hemoglobin and under not
so optimal circumstances it will sickle
and they'll have a crisis and certainly
can die from it now this is in the black
community the white Community the same
disease is called
phemia and they call it phemia because
you can't have a black Gene in a white
guy or white Gene and black guy so they
call the same disease in two different
groups two different names I always
thought that was kind of interesting and
it began to fill in the blanks for me as
a researcher doing all these
autopsies same thing with lactose
intolerance the lactase enzyme which is
formed in the pancreas and and the upper
small intestine the mechanisms for
farming that enzymes are dysfunctional
because mama was missing a mineral when
that was farming and so the equipment
doesn't work after the baby's born but
you can
a a um lactase enzyme capsule before you
go to an ice cream party you won't be
uncomfortable and embarrass yourself and
and so forth totally preventable same
way with type 1 diabetes is not genetic
type 1 diabetes is an inborn air
metabolism you're supposed to have
something like 500,000 beta cells in an
island of langerhan in which your body
makes insulin but when kids are born
with a type 1 diabetus they might only
have say 50 or 100 of these beta cells
and they have just just enough insulin
to squeak by when um they're three 6 8
10 12 years old but they're going
through puberty you know 10 to 12 uh
they're starting to do more physical
activities and it's not enough insulin
and so they show up as a type 1 diabetic
at that point totally preventable and
certainly at this point not reversible
lipid storage disease there's enzymes
missing what happens is as a person
grows older they be they get mental
diseases because they're missing the
enzymes that are required to move bats
into cells and out of cells so what do
we have left here well Eugenics of
course was um Francis gon's way of
looking at it but it's really
epigenetics epigenetics is is a science
that takes the place of genetics and
notice the subtitle in the book
epigenetics is the death of the genetic
theory disease transmission that's based
on facts as you'll see here in a moment
and black jeene lies uh Pastor Klo
dollar from Atlanta Georgia and and the
World Changers Church um because I had
helped his daughter get rid of a
lifelong terrible terrible uh form of
asthma and he was told it was genetic in
the black community he was told that his
daughter was not doing very well uh and
she was not going to make it she wasn't
responding to uh various medications
that normally would help other kids with
asthma and so when when it was said that
she wasn't responding to medication I
knew immediately that she wasn't
absorbing the medication is why she
wasn't responding so we put on a
gluten-free dot to increase her
efficiency of absorption got her in the
90 cents of nutrients and her asthma
went away in two weeks because we're
giving her the raw materials and she was
able to absorb the raw materials for her
body to make all the various hormones
that are necessary to dilate the broni
okay we were able to support and promote
maintenance repairs of that system well
he actually funded the first um 100,000
copies of this book Black Jee lies he
said doc I want you to get information
do the research and find all the
diseases are said to be genetic in the
black community diabetes heart disease
cancer Alzheimer disease um and CLE cell
anemia and find out what's going on here
and which diseases are genetic which
ones aren't what we can do to prevent
the ones that aren't and how to cure the
ones we can and of course all this
information is in the book Black Gene
lies high pressure is not genetic even
in the black population Hood pressure is
usually due to a simple mineral
deficiency or maybe when you have kidney
failure um the kidneys will release a
hormone called renin re n i n to drive
your blood pressure up to try and get
more dirty blood into the filtering
units but it certainly is not a genetic
thing totally preventable and in most
cases reversible with the proper
supplement program the death of genetic
the disease transmission now James
Watson the director of The Cold
Springs um genetic research laboratory
in New York and in Manhattan Island did
not coin that phrase I coined that
phrase okay but he did say that he did
say that um
all the experiments they had done over
the last 60 years in genetics had been
irrelevant you could you could actually
I'm quoting him now you can actually
sequence the genes of 150,000 people a
day who had disease we believed were
genetically transmitted diseases uh
things like cancer diabetes CLE cell
anemia uh and the reason why we weren't
able to deal with them was because they
were genetic well he said all that was
irrelevant because none of those
diseases are genetic there either a
chemical problem chemistry problem
biochemistry problem AKA nutritional
deficiencies and I then after he said
that in public I coined the term the
death of the genetic theory disee
transmission remember there's thousands
of failed medical theories every Century
in the 20th century and the 21st century
are no different one of the failed
theories in the 20th century in 21st
century is the genetics cause disease
it's not true you can see how a human
embryo develops and if anything's
missing along the way something's wrong
with the liver they get a cleft pallet
they get cereal py they get spinabifida
they get down syndrome all nutritional
deficiencies as the embryo develops
totally preventable in many cases such
as sosis and muscular isy even after the
baby's born the reversible with
supplementation because they're a
biochemical problem not a mechanical
physical problem one of the places that
doctors do good work is saving premies
100 years ago baby born a pound and a
half most of them didn't make it today
maybe 85 90% will make it but those two
and three months in the incubators of
Special Care is not cheap it cost
$280,000 to $500,000 per baby whe they
make it or not and guess what for
$600 worth of supplements you can
prevent premies you can prevent all
birth effects in babies Down syndrome is
actually caused by deficiency of a
single mineral we've learned this in
animals and we've eliminated in animals
and of course one out of 700 babies in
America are born with Down Syndrome I've
been able to actually prevent and
reverse Down syndrome in an embryo the
most famous one in two and a half months
of pregnancy was Lauren Canal evil conal
was a niece in-law and she called me and
she had an amniocentesis and she had an
ultrasound both of which said she had a
very severely Afflicted Down Syndrome
baby everybody wanted to have an
abortion she didn't want to do that she
contacted me and asked if I could help
her we gave her the 90 cents of
nutrients 16 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids Three fatty acids
gave her a little bit extra that mineral
that's missing when you have Down
syndrome and guess what after N9 month
full-term pregnancy her baby was born
perfectly normal I've done this many
times since but obviously that's the
most famous family I've been dealing
with um triom 21 or down
syndrome Cal palsy is a good example of
a gradient disease depending on how
severe the deficiencies are during the
development of the cerebellum the part
of the brain that actually um functions
to control and stimulate a proper um
function of find muscles small muscles
and um if you're if you're born with a
cerebellum that's the size of a
tangerine all the pieces are there
you're going to be born normal but let's
say you're born with a 10%
underdevelopment you're going to walk
like Charlie Chaplain but that might be
a manageable and controllable with
braces and physical therapy let's say
you're 25% underdeveloped of your of
your
cerebellum you going be flopping around
with your arms and legs what's going to
happen here is um you will look like a a
classic cereal Poes patient if you're
50% underdeveloped you're going to be
with a wheelchair for the rest of your
life because there's not enough size and
function of the cerebellum to actually
do the mechanical things you need for
muscle function this girl here has as
much as a 90% underdevelopment the only
thing that she could voluntarily move
herself or her eyes you notice the
clamps holding her head up you notice
the the shoulder clamps and harnesses
holding her chest back in the chair you
can see where her legs are Shackled into
the chair because she had such terrible
sural pulse that she is flopping all
over like a fish out of water and she
had to be restrained in this way this
child cost $5 million a year to care for
requires enormous amount of care now the
interesting thing about this child uh
when she goes through puberty and cycles
and gets married and has kids she can
have perfectly normal kids even if her
spouse even if her husband has yes
cereal palsy because it's not a genetic
disease they can have normal babies if
they getting if they're getting all the
90 cenal nutrients prior to cons ception
of course the cerebellum um the part of
the brain that looks like a pomegranate
that's has been cut through in the
backside of the brain stem there in this
picture um this is the part of the brain
that's Afflicted when you have cereal
paly the smaller it is more severe the
cerebral paly this's another one of my
lawsuits against the FDA and federal
court and basically uh what what you see
here is two little kids newborns with a
spine AIP
and of course spinabifida often times
occurs in the lumbar area but can occur
anywhere up and down the spine the one
on the right also has a um zinc
deficiency it has club feet spinit is
due to a folic acid deficiency and I'm
one of the three guys we got together
and actually Su the FDA and that's why
we have folic acid in prenal vins to
prevent spinabifida siames twins are
co-joined at the pelvis these things are
all caused by nutritional deficiencies
during pregnancy here's really
incomplete siamese triplets you see
three sets of legs there um the complete
child also has a club right foot meaning
a zinc deficiency the incomplete um
other um part of the triplets here are
just from the hips down so you see three
sets of legs but the only complete child
is the one bigger one you see and all
this is certainly preventable by proper
supplementation prior to conception all
90 essential
nutrients congenital deafness is caused
by deficiency of a single mineral it's
not genetic in any way shape or form and
doctors continue to form agencies and
programs to beg for money to find out
the gene so kids won't be born deaf if
the mother takes the the prenatal
vitamins preconception vitamins and
minerals prior to conception there won't
be any more children Barn deaf because
it's a simple Minal deficiency a single
Minal deficiency same way with clef pel
clef lip totally caused by a deficiency
of a single mineral in the early stages
of pregnancy when the when the flat disc
of the embryo begins to curl up into a
tube and the tube doesn't close all at
once it closes like a zipper so you can
have a defect anywhere along the
underside of that embryo and of course
this is the last stages of closing the
embryo and the zipper is the mouth and
the pallet the middle and the left-and
picture are babies that have been
grously impacted by thalidomide a drug
that was given to women for morning
sickness early in pregnancy and it
interfered with zinc metabolism in the
embryos and caused
the loss and prevention of the of the
production of Limbs arms and legs a
terrible terrible thing there's a
similar thing goes on in a village in
Russia where about an average of 300
kids are born there every year this one
Village half of them have the same
defect on both sides of their body 25%
have the defect on their right side 25%
have the defect on their left side they
don't have solomite but they do have a
deficiency of that same mineral and you
can see where the these kids were
gathered together by the photographers
to show they all had missing left
forearms cute little kids but they're
all missing their left fors uh totally
totally preventable while the doctors
are telling them it's a genetic disease
in that Community we've all heard of the
Greek mythology of the Cyclops evil
giant um and here's a cyclopic kitten
here's a cycloptic
lamb here's a cycloptic shark and what
this tells you is when you have three
different species here having the same
problem the same deficiency will cause
cycloptic anatomy in all verteb any
vertebrate that has a deficiency of this
nutrient at that particular moment of
the development of the embryo will wind
up cycloptic including humans and so
this is why we had that um Greek
mythology there were babies born in
those days with cycloptic eyes as there
is
today there is a human baby with Cyclops
uh you can see that there's no nose
between the eyes and the upper lip the
nose is above the uh eye and of course
this is a very very terrible uh birth
effect and most of the time when they do
a Ultra sound and they see this defect
the parents choose to uh do an abortion
uh many of
miscarriages are because these are have
low viability these babies with a
cycloptic defect and um they will be
miscarried and so I don't know what the
percentage is but it's very high of
miscarried babies or cyclopic babies we
look at animals where we have control
not wild animals we don't know the rate
in wild animals but in domestic animals
we have farm animals and pet animals as
one in 16,000 have um cycloptic Anatomy
in humans when you take in the
miscarriages is one of 250 why is that
that's because we supplement animals to
rent birth the effects and human beings
you're just told to eat well most women
will miss two periods before they start
taking prenatal vitamins by that time
the embryo is impacted the single mother
had one child born with 38 birth effects
one child with 38 birth effects we're
talking about spinabifida heart defects
Club limbs cerebral paly and she gets
help financially from 38 different
agency that raises money to do research
on these things somebody needs to go to
jail here and I would vote for the obj1
that managed that pregnancy in 1977 I
discovered the first non-human case of
cisy vibrosis and a monkey at the yis
primate Center in Atlanta
Georgia and this was emry University gr
Memorial Hospital all the experts on
their letterhead agreed that the tissues
were in fact sosis then I told them it
was from a non-human monkey and they
were all excited say oh we have a
laboratory animal now we can study ciss
rosis well having already done by this
time all this research um with the
center for the biology of natural
systems Marlon Perkins Washington
University the St Louis Zoo Char
botanical gardens written 75 scientific
papers I knew what to look for and began
to look for what might cause this birth
effect and everybody said it was genetic
well I found that it was due to a
deficiency of a single
mineral deficiency of a single mineral
was able to go back into the colony
where this baby monkey was being raised
for NASA for space projects there were
unrelated monkeys baby monkeys the same
age that still were alive but they had
the disease got permission to do
biopsies of their pancreases and livers
and lungs and sure enough they all had
sosis they were not related genetically
in any way shape or form gave them the
mineral that was missing and cured them
all wrote it up as for permission to get
it published and I was fired from em
University in York primary said wall you
must be sniffing glue everybody knows
that cisis is genetically transmitted
well why don't you call together a
committee like you would
for um challenging ing a thesis for a
PhD student get geneticist get experts
in sosis get pediatricians and let them
challenge my evidence let me bring my
evidence and respond to them if I can
satisfy them they're all agreed then we
can move forward and get grants and save
kids but if we can't then go ahead and
farm me they said no we'd be embarrassed
to tears to call together such a
committee because everybody knows that
it's genetically transmitted and this is
the press released from emry University
in March of
1978 um when they knew that we had a
non-human case of cisy rosis they were
very excited about it and they wanted to
get credit for it so they sent out this
positive news release and then they
fired me in another month when I told
them it wasn't genetic okay well this is
from June of 2005 June of 2005 the
international laboratory animal research
Journal you notice it says serendipitous
insights involving non-human primates
this was uh the entire Journal this
issue was uh dealing with Primate
Research in human diseases because at
this time the federal government had
actually defunded Primate Research is
too expensive $1,000 a day for primates
used mice is only 10 cents a day if you
have to use primates go to the Gates
Foundation get money from them the
government's not going to pay for it and
so they took the top 10 serendipitous
findings the top 10 accidental findings
in primary research that benefited
Humanity so well said look even just by
accident we found these things and
number two out of the top 10 for the
20th century was the discovery of the
first non-human cases sistic fosis my
work and there was like three paragraphs
in the in that piece on the ciss rosis
and the last sentence the last portion
of that sentence they had brackets and
said and Emory University refused to
release the name of the young
pathologist who made the discovery close
brackets because they were so
embarrassed that they had fired me and
now they were using my work to try and
save their research programs one of the
reasons why they didn't want it to be a
simple nutritional deficiency disease
because the yearly cost just for the
respiratory piece just for the
respiratory piece of C Bros n a
digestive piece also and liver piece
also but for just the respiratory piece
the cost for one patient is 200 almost
$260,000 a year so why they want to give
up that kind of income just by telling
the truth this is why the medical system
tends to fail us is because they work
for the money as opposed to the truth
these are some of the kids that I deal
with with a little Sydney Myers in
Fort Wayne Indiana she was supposed to
have a double lung transplant two and a
half years of age her parents didn't
have insurance didn't have money so they
came to me and we put her on the program
and here she is six and a half years
later winning a dance contest and of
course she's perfectly normal at this
time and she'll be able to have normal
babies and no problem now an opportunity
came along in 1989 for me to go to kesan
Province China I went to kishan Province
China to do autopsies on kids that died
of kishan's disease which is a
deficiency of a single mineral now the
same mineral is the same deficiency that
causes Cy her
brosis now that's not unusual people say
w you must be infatuated that mineral no
Calcium deficiency can result in 147
different diseases zinc deficiency is a
big big cause of many different birth
effects and so this mineral deficiency
selenium is no different probably 25
different diseases caused by slam
deficiency well Kean disease as is
called is named after the Province in
China where it occurs so frequently
because there are little or no of of
this mineral selenium in the soil there
plants that they grow corn and wheat
don't require selenium and when these
poor farm kids eat these grains they get
plenty of calories maybe a little
protein but they don't get any of those
mineral and thousands of them die every
month there's over 300 million people in
that one state there's over 300 million
people in those provinces so when a
couple of thousand kids die every month
it's a serious problem obviously but
it's not like it's an epidemic going
through and killing millions and so per
month and so this is one of those things
where uh they just sort of learn to live
with it they would supplement the these
kids with selenium and they saved many
of them by doing that so I went there
and I said if I'm correct and Cy rosis
is caused by congenital selenium
efficiency by a deficiency of selenium
during pregnancy and some of these kids
in China and Kean promised are going to
have CYS brosis and I took that thought
to people who are geneticists and people
who were experts in in cistos they
laughed at me again well now we know
where you got fired you're really dumb
because Chinese kids don't get Cy rosis
is it really I've autopsies Oriental
kids and black kids that had sosis and I
went to China did 1,700 autopsies 1,700
autopsies in this program and I was
hoping for one or three or five or
something like that kids of C rosis well
it turns out that 35% 595 of them had
CIS brosis out of the 1700 it was
unimpeachable evidence the slides are
still there in the universities where
the work was done it can be tracked we
can redo the study again we'll have the
same same result I guarantee that sent
copies of this published in English
published in Chinese and peer review
refereed scientific journals and guess
what sent them to the C brosis
Foundation never had a response they
should have their nonprofit status taken
away from them because every child
that's born with cystic fosis or dies of
cystic fosis is on their head somebody
needs to go to jail okay well I got a
three for when I did those 1,700
autopsies because they also found out
the cause prevention cure for musular
disy worked on that for years actually
uh worked with uh the Amish communities
which have a very high rate of mustard
isy and guess what we're able to support
and promote maintenance repair reverse
mustardy even their own doctors said was
reversed gave Jerry Lewis um from the
musard hisory foundation uh copies of
many of these kids reports and their
their records showing even their doctors
said they had had their mustard disy
reversed he took it to the mustard isue
foundation and they fired Jerry Lewis
for insisting that they look at this
seriously they fired Jerry Lewis again I
believe they should have their their um
tax exempt status taken away from them
because every time a kid is born with
musy or dies from it it's on their head
somebody needs to go to jail cardiovas
disease we've already talked about this
briefly a congestive heart fill
deficiency of a single vitamin cardiy
heart disease kesan disease is a
deficiency of a single mineral carnate
artery disease is caused by inflammation
eating fried foods processed Meats oils
microwave popcorn all that kind of stuff
and then coronary thrombosis is caused
by an omega-3 essential fatty acid
deficien and none of these cardiovas
diseases is caused by what cholesterol
or saturated fat it was a sales campaign
to sell
Crisco remember Proctor and Gamble gave
the American Heart Association brokered
by anel Keys $1.7 million to endorse
Crisco and demonize cholesterol records
show now that that the heart age of of
most people in the industrialized world
including America are older than their
chronological age and men at 7.8 years
older and women 5.6 years old that's
because of the eating of trans fats and
heterocyclic amines which cause
particular inflammation in the in the
coronary arteries and cause heart
disease and this just shows you a map
what part of the continental United
States and the islands of Hawaii and
Alaska have the highest rates of um
heart ages that are far older than their
chronological age here's one of the bad
boys when it comes to cardiovascular
disease microwave popcorn we're seeing
more and more kids uh we're talking
about eight 10 year olds three year olds
two-y olds dying of heart disease
coronary art disease because what oh
they're being babysat with microwave
popcorn you know the parents can't
afford babysitters so they give them a
bag of microwave popcorn let them watch
TV or put on a a giggly cartoon movie
while they're doing work in the
kitchen and uh these kids are dead by
the the time they're in their teens and
early 20s microwave popcorn contributes
to 50,000 heart attacks a year 20,000
deaths front page story in the USA Today
now the new krisco of course Again
demonized by the American Heart
Association exchange for $1.7 million um
Proctor and Gamble always trying to
expand their market and what they wanted
to do was have you deep fry your
Thanksgiving turkey in Crisco instead of
roasting it like we've done
traditionally since the days of the
Revolution the new Chrisco made to help
take the fat worry out of good eating
well who put the fat worry into it the
American Heart Association by demonizing
cholesterol and saturated fat of course
all this story came from two full pages
of the New York Times And basically
we're talking about saturated fat does
not cause heart
disease okay and of course this goes
back to Dr anel Keys again he was uh
through his force of will I mean this
guy was one of these bombastic guys he
could pound on the podium and yell and
scream and people believed him because
he was so forceful and he drove the use
of Crisco rather than milk and cream and
um butter and eggs and lard now in
addition to demonizing cholesterol ins
saturated fat they actually looked at
making it sexier to use Crisco and so
they looked at the a of creit and came
up with a Mediterranean diet in fact the
Mediterranean diet was a fraud it was a
sales campaign to sell krisco there's no
evidence to back up any of the claims
for the Mediterranean diet fried foods
trans fats caused stroke they contribute
to the inflammation of arteries um that
cause stroke if you're deficient
Omega-3s and you're eating a lot of
fried foods you're going to get a stroke
if even if you're two years old even if
you're six months
old Kean province in the red here
selenium depleted red area
now you've all heard of Sid sudden
infant death syndrome and of course
another failed theory was doctors said
that Sid was caused by the baby sleeping
on their back what a dumb theory that
was they didn't use the special stains
to see if
the SIDS was caused by heart disease in
fact these kids that died of Sids when
they're two months old two weeks old was
caused by a deficiency of selenium was
kean's disease I did the special stains
because I'm a a pathologist that looks
at those details and so we actually sued
the FDA for many years trying to get
selenium into prenatal formulas and also
into infant formulas after the baby's
born and we had a big fight they didn't
like the idea that this might deal with
genetic disease like C Bros musicity so
when we talked about SIDS um they signed
off on that one they signed off on that
one let us put it in infant FAL is in
fact is required slum is now required in
infant phos to deal with SIDS but
through the back door we're also going
to eliminate muscular free and ciss
fibrosis because it'll also deal with
that so uh we had to do little ctitious
things there and go through the back
door to get a 3fer these are the sort of
kids that would die from kishan disease
from a SL deficiency because they lived
entirely on wheat and corn in a place
that had little or no selenium in the
soil Dr Fred Kern professor of medicine
at the University of Colorado was H
training a bunch of newly graduated
medical doctors on how to examine
seniors and he found this chart of an
88y old guy he says come on let's go
examine this guy goes in the examining
room and he looks at him he says is this
you he points to the Chart he says is
this you yeah he says the chart here
says you're 88 years old you don't look
that old he says yeah people say I look
like I'm 50 he says what do you
attribute your youthful looks to and
you're 88 years old and he said
I eat 25 eggs a day I've been doing it
for 17 years I'm going to do it for
another 100 years well of course this is
not what Dr Kern was looking for in
front of these students and I I it
didn't say it in the article but I
guarantee he sat down he's Fanning
himself with his clipboard okay sir why
are you eating 25 eggs a day and the guy
stands up throws his chest out throws
his shoulders back and said because it
makes me more studly now you think about
that when you look at testosterone
estrogen progesterone adrenal hormones
are all steroid hormones and they're 95%
by weight cholesterol
they 95% by weight cholesterol you want
a cholesterol restricted diet you're
taking stat and drugs to lower your
cholesterol there's nobody home anymore
you get a rectile dysfunction low tea
women go into menopause when they're 35
years old and start getting hot flashes
and night sweats and they stop cycling
when they're 35 40 years old because
they're not making enough hormones you
get adrenal exhaustion but even more
importantly than all that we had a new
disease a new Big Boy disease called
Alzheimer disease 45 years years ago
alimer disease didn't exist even by
another name today it's a number four
killer of adults over the age of 65 it's
driven it's a physician caused
disease 75% of the human brain weight is
the white matter of the brain the myin
it's called myelin it's the insulation
material of the brain and this myelin
that makes up 75% of your brain weight
is 100%
cholesterol so you go to cholesterol
restricted diet no
more cholesterol in your blood or very
little because you're getting it down to
like a 100 with statin drugs you're
going to get Alzheimer dis disase it's
an
Alzheimer's Alzheimer disease is a a um
preventable disease it's a reversible
disease and um this is the entire story
of saturated fat and cholesterol and
Time Magazine want you look at anel keys
on the left part of your screen and anel
keys here um I mean he even looks like a
Nazi he was um actually put on the cover
of Time Magazine is the hero who saved
the American cardiov vestus um system by
identifying col and sat fat is the evil
ones he was the one that demonized him
cholesterol on the front page of Time
Magazine and this is the sort of way
this is the method they use to demonize
cholesterol on your right hand part of
your screen Time Magazine eat butter big
scoop of butter on the cover and this is
a article obviously cover Story five
pages talks about the story with Ansel
keys and how he' um got Pon gamble to
endorse a diesel engine submarine
lubricant for cooking as opposed to
butter cream lard and
eggs in this one on the right hand side
Time Magazine eat butter this is from
June 23rd 2014 say scientists labeled
fats saturated fat the enemy and why
they were wrong you need to read that
one and you'll realize how badly you've
been defrauded by the medical system and
the pharmaceutical industry the
individuals on Earth the culture on
Earth that has the fewest cardiovascular
events are the inette eskimos above the
Arctic Circle no less than a dozen times
a year there's articles printed in
scientific journals on these peoples and
they're kind of unique they just don't
get cardiovascular disease and yet 98%
of their traditional diet above the
arctic circle is red meat and fat they
eat nothing but whale meat and whale
blubber walrus meat and walus blubber
seal meat and seal blubber bare meat and
bare fat they don't eat vegetables or
fruit they don't eat nuts and grain
their cholesterols run 350 to
500 they don't get cardiov disease until
they come down into the lower 48 and eat
like us salt is not bad salt has two
essential nutrients in it's sodium and
chloride required for all kinds of
chemical reactions inside cells can't
live without sodium chloride and of
course um chlorine is also required to
make stomach acid to keep your stomach
sterile to help pepsin the enzyme digest
proteins amino acids and help the
Castle's intrinsic factor to absorb B12
also to absorb most minerals you're
going to require uh stomach acid you're
going to get reflux if you don't have
enough stomach acid to keep your stomach
sterle because yeast and bacteria will
grow in there and so you need stomach
acid to keep your sterile anybody who
tells you to restrict your salt because
of Highwood pressure should be put in
jail somebody needs to go to jail here
1982 salt a new villain 2014 Salt
doesn't cause high blood pressure this
shows you death rates okay from heart
disease and then of course in February
of 2012 the FDA sent an urgent stop
email to all licensed medical doctors in
America it says stop writing
prescription for statin drugs lipor
zokor meore leost Statin these kinds of
things
and they listed them on that email stop
writing prescriptions for these drugs
stop telling your patients to get on
cluster restricted diets because if you
continue to do this you're going to
increase the risk of type 2 diabetes by
52% and Alzheimer's Disease by 100% four
months later Science News June of
2012 good cholesterol not so beneficial
wait a minute your doctor says it's
everything of course they say is not
beneficial and then they went on to say
that higher HDL high density Lio protein
the good cholesterol High good
cholesterol levels don't reduce the rate
of heart disease or heart attacks why is
that because no heart disease is caused
by cholesterol or saturated fat remember
congestive heart fi is caused by
deficiency of single vitamin card the
heart disease caused by deficiency of
single mineral coronary AR disease is
caused by inflammation and thrombotic
heart disease car thrombosis blood clot
in the coronary artery or brain artery
is caused not by cholesterol ins
saturated fat but an omega-3 essential
fatty acid deficiency margarin
is the worst type of fat for the heart
and this includes the margin that's in
between the chocolate cookies and Oreo
cookies and here's the front cover story
FDA to trim trans fats out of food and I
thought they were too lenient on the
people who had trans fats in their Foods
they manufactur they gave them three
months to do it and that's 90 days uh
when you have so many thousands of
people dying from this or young kids
dying from this somebody needs to go to
jail let's look at athletes real quickly
exercise is thought to be a very very
good thing it can be we've done properly
but let's look at professional athletes
look at amateur athletes and let's look
at their average lifespan let's look at
how long they live Jim fixed the darling
in the medical world because he said you
don't have to supplement all you have to
do is um run and you'll keep your
arteries clean he died 52 while he was
running his Protege his top student
Brian Maxwell from Canada died at age 51
while running he had 12 gold medals in
longdistance running three of which were
in the Olympics